herzlich willkommen bei minecraft lehrer
hallo und herzlich willkommen
warum bewegte sich nicht sagen
so leute falls ihr euch fragt was zur
hölle geht er ab warum stützrad da
drüben und staat so auf den computer
erich und patrick ein bisschen gefehlt
am anfang
wir dachten nämlich kommen wir schneiden
das raus aber bei minecraft nero wird
jede minute aufgenommen ab dem beginn wo
man auf dem server ist und
dementsprechend haben wir einfach lange
zeit nicht geredet und gar nichts
gemacht und deshalb ist die folge ein
bisschen ort und ich habe mich
entschieden so ein bisschen aus dem
schnitt noch zu euch zu sprechen und zu
sagen was eigentlich abkommen erst mal
das ganze essen hier am spawn mit ja
klar du stehst du ich hab ich hab 64
stakes hierbei in einem gefunden
guter mann jetzt folgt bekommt jetzt
jetzt gehen wir los läuft die aufnahme
eigentlich schon ja ne also absolut ab
sofort mit ja dann noch mal leute
herzlich willkommen alle freunde
dann sollten aber herzlich willkommen zu
minecraft nero die erste folge nehme ich
hier mit patrick auf was geht was geht
ab leute krankhaft und flexibel
seit jetzt müssen wir erstmal das portal
würden wir sind ja in hamburg also sie
als ob die portale sind wir wollen was
ihr jetzt schon mal das portal von statt
blau gelb aufgeregt oder ich bin nicht
aufgeregt ich habe seit zwei wochen kein
gängigen also überhaupt nicht
aufgenommen ich muss das mal wieder rein
kommen leute die haspa hat worauf alle
hier gott oh gott da ist ein monster gut
wie kommen wir zum portal alle kämpfen
losgeht wo wirst du patrick wir müssen
zum portal von stadtgrün das ist
wahrscheinlich auf der anderen seite
also die erste folge wären wir aber
keine progressive machen denke ich mal
also ich versuche uns aber als ob das
tier ist man jetzt offiziell folge oder
eben doch das zählt schon als offizielle
folge und bis dahin haben wir so ganz
normal geredet ob als ob es irgendwie
normale folge wäre so einigermaßen
einfach
der wird irgendwann euro verlieren aber
alle wussten diese portale contest ihr
portal siehst du doch bis dahin leute
wie gesagt gerade eben was nochmals
spannend als sie angegriffen wurde von
diesem baum dachten wir uns bestimmt
können wir das ausschneiden weil der
anfang so komisch war und wird das
portal ewig nicht gefunden haben und so
weiter und so fort
es war aber nicht so deshalb erstmal ein
paar grundlegende worte zu minecraft
nero minecraft nero basiert auf dem
advanced office engine motto pack das 14
neue dimensionen zu wie ich auch später
noch sagen werde
da an den platten magic mode und viele
viele weitere
ich habe mir für den anfang überlegt
dass wir erst mal mit blood magic
beschäftigen werden und da
ja profi werde bzw relativ gut drin
werde und mich dann in den weiteren
folgen anderen mods widmen kann
so jetzt bin ich in die stadt gekommen
okay die anderen kommen auch alle
langsam an so
es ist schon wieder so komisch so dass
sie einfach überhaupt nicht rede und
einfach da kann gar kein flop sitze
es ist komisch als davos im kino stieg
wollten ja die usa sind richtig
gefährlich okay okay okay da wir in
ständen sind beginnen jetzt einfach die
folge wir auch sagen mach jetzt mal ja
obwohl sie eigentlich ganz meinen job
gut angefangen so leute wir sind jetzt
in den städten
ich bin christ geschnitten dass man
falls holz holz holz also ich habe mir
nicht ein bisschen wir müssen sagen das
sind freunde dass dieses markt gut sein
wird und warum ist das holz
es gibt hier einige grafische mord die
das ganze aussehen lassen so die
animation auch wenn das drobs richtig
nice und generell ist aus mega lass mal
dass man direkt hier ein auf warum
machern solberg band hier stick da dreck
schweres match races wichtigste dann
gehen wir auch direkt schon stein fahren
am anfang haben wir noch nicht viel
mopac relevantes machen ich weiß nicht
hast du dich schon ein bisschen damit
auseinander gesetzt oder soll ich was
erzählen
ich war also erzählt wahrscheinlich auch
für den zuschauer ein bisschen
interessant und zwar gibt es hier ja
mehrere ich habe gerade eine höhle
vertritt dazu kommt aber nach meinem
namen ich bin schon untergrund in
richtung weidmann hier aus hass
wie kann ich hier durch die gegner hast
du dir jetzt ab sofort auf jeden fall
nicht sterben was versteht ppv ppw auch
in der er quasi in der regel dass man
halt aussetzen muss ist lässt das da
unten das ist du accra nie okay wie soll
man sagen steuern beträgt also los auf
mutter so weil mit dem streit also mit
dem stein schwert ist man auch schon mal
gut gewappnet
münster die hammer umzulegen normal
ich finde ich bin ein bisschen schade
dass ich nicht dass man nicht schneiden
darf ja einerseits ist das schade meint
man darf aber auch trotzdem sachen
einfügen du darfst du darfst nicht
weglassen ist kann er zum beispiel meine
facebook trotzdem eher größer mal mit
ihrem sohn mal was verdeutlichen oder
jetzt musik stoppen so vom dinge wenn
ich bock sachen zwischen für sowas darf
hier auch alles von daher finde ich ist
es nicht so schlimm
man kann sich hier übrigens auch so
fackeln in der hand halten dann leuchten
die auch bist du ich bin hier
ich baue gerade schon die das erste 1
ich wollte ja ich wollte ein bisschen
was erzählen von den hot packs das haus
nottbeck hier advance auf sc 03 11
engine heißt das dass fügt 14 neue
dimension hinzu die man das ist richtig
dass also 14 neue dimension mit jeweils
eigenen bossgegnern das ist relativ
aufwendig die portal zu bauen
aber ich hab auch relativen also es ist
machbar auf jeden fall aber ich glaube
das steht auf jeden fall erst in den
fortgeschrittenen folgen an solche es
ist auf jeden fall ich habe gesehen also
in die ganzen dimension gibt es auch
bosnien & drop auf jeden fall schon das
ein oder andere größere es gibt heftig
geile sachen so wenn ihr mal schaut hier
in modena films gibt es 63 seiten was
unglaublich ist auch richtig richtig
cool items ich brauche meine spiele ich
habe erstmal angst vom dinge dass die
mod also dass das model ein bisschen
also sehr komplex sein würde das geht ab
auf jeden fall am anfang ich mal mit
blood magic vor allem beschäftigen
ich weiß nicht kennst du dich damit auch
schon aus
ich habe mir vorgenommen hat dieser
folge also ich hätte jetzt auch keine
weitere aufnehmen heute ich werde mich
schon ein bisschen auseinandersetzen mit
dem moped und dann mir in der zweiten
folge überlegen was ich machen will
welche richtung ich gehen werde
aber ich bin also ich werde die haben ja
die vorgebaute starten und ja keine
ahnung ich werde jetzt nicht so viel
bauen stadt erkunden oder zeiten
allgemein schlag das eso zu erkunden und
zu fighten bosse klar wie viel essen das
versperrte ein steak und eine karotte
okay dann gebe ich hier noch mal ein
bisschen nach
ein level up in den du hast in level
abbekommen denkmal oder leer oder neben
ist das ein bisschen komisch dass man
das einfach übers würfel für land er
musste ja auch wahr wir sollten auf die
verler mitnehmen ich habe dir gesagt man
kann mit markant erfrieren egal wessen
die jungen aber nacht meinen
warum setzen eigentlich läuft das weil
die stern glaube ich ach so ja nein ja
npcs haben die gekillt
deshalb wird er wahrscheinlich warum hat
stiegen 1 dastehen
das ist kiel ist da recht was ich sagen
wollte ist habe ich vergessen schade
na ja genau ja so schnell kann man an
existieren ja nee also die die dungeons
sind jetzt nicht so über hero damals
hinzugefügt wurden sondern es sind
hast du mir eisen glück hast du nicht
dadurch nicht rein getan habt ihr
angetan ich bin ein guter verbündeter
also ich hab wirklich also unsere seite
es war richtig froh als du die stadt
gekommen ist ich habe mich richtig
gefreut also wirklich cool
ja ich bin die relation von spontanen
reingekommen jetzt einmal auf die letzte
ich hab mich so ich wollte auch leute
und dann ich habe die ganze zeit gemerkt
im gruppenchat so dass alles schon
gesprochen wurde so zum beispiel die
regel hatte ich am anfang nicht ich
musste mir besorgen und all diese dinge
aber ich komm flieg gab es schon seit
100 aber ich bin jetzt wirklich nicht
unvorbereitet heißt dass manch einer
glaubt sondern ich habe mich extrem gut
vorbereitet heute muss ich sagen besser
als ich sie jemals habe bei irgendwem ob
eck und dementsprechend bin ich
zuversichtlich meint wir sind stadtgrün
wir haben einige namen sage ich mal was
pvp angeht
wie präsent ist natürlich über dem
durchschnitt auf seiten jetzt halte ich
eigentlich gut aber sonst halt wie du
weißt ich nicht schwierig konforme
schaut einfach extrem gut also eher
kalte kann der kanton habe durch seine
starke stadt also ich würde sogar sagen
die stärkste
also ich habe auch viele kommentare
gelesen statt schack grünen hier statt
vier mega ok lass mal hier weiter wissen
ich weiß gar nicht wie lange die folge
schon gehts ja die folge ist
naja wenn der raw aufnahmen 13 minute
prima daumen gerade so neun minuten ja
genau ich würde auch sagen
vielmehr ist es nicht aber ich freue
mich ich freue mich krass also ich habe
einiges vor ich möchte echt einiges
schaffen
wie gesagt zuerst einmal blatt magic ich
würde sagen gegeben noch mal ein
bisschen tiefer damit wir vielleicht
schon das erste map-pack relevant ja ja
er war ich wirklich mit den fehlenden
eisenstaedt mitzunehmen also machen zwei
hälsen schwertner klappt du hast reicht
auf jeden fall selbst wieder die monster
sind hier helfe ja das weiß ich ja ich
lasse mein schwert bitte ich habe noch
kein selbst macht die reinsten auch in
einem ort relevante sachen bad bauen
willst hier schon mal heißt es reisen
spitz hat ja ich hatte
mir gedacht da haben wir machen
vielleicht finden anfangen den antik
atlas also die map dafür brauchst du
einen kompass und ein buch das buch wird
vielleicht ein bisschen schwer
dafür müssen wir noch mal vielleicht
gegen ende der folge ist überirdisch
gehen aber jetzt brauchen wir erstmal
ein bisschen eisen und redstone halt mit
dem kompass ganz normal als nicht
herausnehme ich hatte sieben reisen soll
sonst jeweils jeweils etwa 100 wir
müssen ein bisschen ich hab auch noch ab
dallas noch beide eine leggins machen
niveau beiden chaplin vorschlag des
briten oder us to find ich hab' ich habe
und habe ich sagen gehen wir auch schon
unterirdisch oder habe ich aus sachsen
haben wir sind wir schon ja essen fertig
fragt wo ich es ganz essen habe gerade
eben am anfang ja das hat der hat
gesehen wir hatten ja da sind abendmahl
tische und über alle saßen da gab
darüber waren überall teller verteilt
essen wir haben ja vergisst die wand
nicht regelt das war das absolute nicht
das durfte man manche teller waren ja
auch leer und ich hab ich habe irgendwie
ein teller erwischt der waren 4
hier ist direkt noch eine neue hürde
vertritt ich habe direkt in die täler
erwischt gehabt da waren 64 tags drauf
knapp der seehofer luton vorher da war
wahrscheinlich irgendwo irgendwelche hex
am start minuten für mich okay erstmal
wissen eisen wir machen erstmal basic
kurve am anfang
redstone wäre halt echt wünschenswert
oder sich seine miene gefunden wo sie es
fertig kam auch zu dir ist auch reisen
direkt ich glaube ich in demmin in den
kisten können auch hot packs lachens von
der mutter ich habe schon probiert die
mit diesem meeting so zu faken dass ich
gestorben bin geht leider nicht die
batterie mach mal das wasser mal
natürlich nicht weg das kenne ich noch
gut gebrauchen mehr auf dem feld
aber hier ist doch tatsächlich diesen
mannschaft
was geiles
die crew fast nicht so stark wie in 19
und jahres schon bestimmt also du weißt
nicht die kräftig wie oft ich ein
krippenspiel das waren nicht wir gucken
uns das ganze mal finden irgend was cool
ist als ob du denn tatsächlich sehr hast
du den eimer schon gemacht ich habe mir
ein gemacht dass man das wasser holen
ich hoffe dass du darfst du abbauen
lässt du gesehen welch verschlagen wird
er das geteilte kommst du mit dir machen
wir 15 15
ich höre das wasser ja so können guckt
euch schon mal weiter im mienenspiel
vorschlag läuft erstmal etwas
aufgefallen ist stellen bis jetzt habe
ich noch keinen mob gesehen na ja bis
auf den spann halten und diesen black
usa der am anfang ist man wieder die
spot ist zum glück das gefühl dass
dabei auch die spontis wasserdruck du
kannst eigentlich her springt ein whisky
mutig die diamanten safetic diesem feld
also ich lass dir mal das wasser hier am
besten dass sie wieder hoch schwimmen
kannst ja weitergehen aber die die höhle
ein bisschen erkunden ob ich irgendwas
findet man verträgt ok wo sind die
genial hilfen wie diamanten geil alter
leute leute freut ihr euch natürlich
freudig komme ob du auch redstone findet
was ja unbedingt von der villa gefallen
nur einer oder wie aber dann schön
außenrum baune die dinger sind auf jeden
fall wichtig ich bräuchte auch unbedingt
einmal ein blatt mit drei diamanten
japaner ist er wie schon eine kiste
gefunden
mal gucken was drin ist kohle beherzte
die sehr fremd mich aussehen das ist
schon mal sehr positiv muss man gucken
haben müssten eigentlich bist du was wir
behindert hat die volg wenn die anderen
auch die folge beenden ganz ehrlich ja
man muss hat in berlin
wenn man nicht die folge beendet das man
muss das ja noch zeigen die server von
reichen deshalb lasst auch beenden wenn
die leute auch liegen also bis zum
maximum gehen ja gut aber ich weiß nicht
wenn halt die letzten gehen gehen wir
auch schon immer noch reisen abbauen und
so ne
die zeit geht nicht vorwärts das würde
nicht nacht meint den er vielleicht das
kann gut sein werden wir den er das als
erstes auffällt noch kann ich nicht
mithalten abbauen
broich mit ihrem an spitzhacke das erste
ernst ott pack gefunden und es ist nicht
ob bau gmbh das lernen kannst du
herausfinden oder welche farbe hat es
also orange zerbröselt das bild also
textur dort auf dem ernst ich komme ja
dann gebt doch einfach mal vorbei
die nach sundance wahrscheinlich schon
sehen kann dass auch darauf auswirken
kann
das können schon seine botschaft ich bin
auch unten kaputt ich habe gar externe
kunden den baum direkt mal ab monster
aus ja diese frage ist zu recht wird
weil ich sie auch keine monster hier
vorne ist das kenne ich auch gar nicht
da vor uns noch ein schwarzes tor
ich guck mal nachdem das ist die liebe
leid und das von ist rooney um ok-team
geld ist ja mal richtig ja mehr richtig
verknackt haben sie mitgenommen
eine holzplanke ok sehr gut mehr braucht
man nicht weil ich ja ich habe drei
die workbench dann nicht vergessen gibt
es immer gibst du mir mal wobei das gas
fix dabei spieler sind alle befehle der
asx also oben ist noch eine work bench
alten ja
gerne
wir müssen wissen was haben aber schon
mal gut dass wir kümmern uns angreifen
aus den us-kongress verbrauchen wir nun
erstmal nur ein er steht wegen den
kompass ja genau
dann brauchen wir noch in wien finden
bestenfalls bzw bücher mikrowelt fertig
nein das war wollen wir uns noch mal
sagt an also ein bisschen mitnehmen
würde sagen hier ja auf jeden fall
wollen wir noch nach oben oder wollen
wir noch ein bisschen die mine
erkundigen
ich meine es macht keinen unterschied
auf finanziellen lagen ausloggen wobei
ja zwei minuten sind noch erzählen sie
ist auch nicht die welt
born auf das stimmt allerdings oben ist
noch gold wurden verschlankt wo ist das
geld da oben ja viele dias hast du erst
bekommen 3-klatsche mir davon acht
kassen wieder von eingeben
später will ich mir damit einen platten
metric alter macht er alles klar macht
dass ich habe mal hast du mir schon
gegeben ja keiner halt einmal hast du in
die lava gegriffen halt dein maul
ich schwöre auf alles ich habe keine sie
hingelegt es kann nicht sein dass es im
lager gefangen ist herr kommentar wieder
zu wasser sagt nicht du hast den in die
lava geholfen junge ich versteh ich
nicht ich schwöre ich schwöre ich bin
wirklich ich hab den 1
probier probleme irgendwas anderes zu
werfen
nein das ist unsichtbar also ich hab den
kohleblock geworfen
das einfach ist also das bakterium okay
ich habe drei mal eingegeben
probier's mal nein das geht wie wenig
rechtsklick also verziehen wird man
werfe irgendwas anderes besser habe
hinrichten
ok ja gold weil das einfach
herausgenommen oder nicht
komm zu mir komm zu mir komm zu mir
danger ich habe besseres im erz gewonnen
das ist besser ist dir ende aus
abmoderation geschadet okay dann brauch
ich das in der nächsten folge ab leute
gefallen lassen doch nach oben da checkt
unsere stadt aus und die an teilnehmern
durchaus ich freue mich freut ihr euch
aus haut rein bis zum nächsten mal
disconnect macht's gut auch von meiner
seite